In the film industry, a single film can make or
break a career. This has been the
case since the dawn of Hollywood.
The 2008 vampire romance movie
"Twilight" set its leads up for stardom,
based on a best-selling book series
with a built-in, eager fan base.
"The Twilight Saga" resulted in five films
and was a pop culture phenomenon at the time,
but not every star of the franchise
reaped the long-term rewards.
While two of the leads, Kristen Stewart and
Robert Pattinson, have been able to find
critical and commercial success following
the end of the "Twilight" franchise,
the series' third lead, Taylor
Lautner, has not been as fortunate.
This is actually kind of a surprise,
seeing as the actor's role as the
perennially shirtless werewolf,
Jacob Black, looked like a pretty safe pass to
stardom, and Lautner was perfectly convincing
in the role — as convincing as anyone could be
playing a smoldering, young, jacked wolfman.
"So you're a werewolf."
"Yeah. Last time I checked."
Nevertheless, Lautner, who played
Jacob across all five films,
has failed to turn his "Twilight" exposure to
A-list stardom, while Pattinson and Stewart
have both managed to star in a healthy mix
of mainstream hits and critical darlings.
In fact, since the release of "The Twilight
Saga: Breaking Dawn – Part 2" in 2012, Lautner's
appearances in movies or television has been
noticeably more limited than you might assume.
However, this relatively unimpressive trajectory
hasn't necessarily been Lautner's own fault.
In fact, one might argue that his
dwindling career can be traced back
to a single film — an action thriller that
single-handedly ruined Taylor Lautner's career.
"That doesn't look like me."
To be perfectly honest, Lautner is no stranger
to movies that got a poor critical reception.
The "Twilight" movies weren't beloved by
critics, and his first starring vehicle,
"The Adventures of Sharkboy and Lavagirl,"
was disliked by both critics and audiences.
The 2010 ensemble comedy "Valentine's
Day," which to be fair he only appeared
in relatively briefly, has a
Rotten Tomatoes score of 18%.
"And Felicia, what is it
about Willy that's so cool?"
"Besides the fact that he's totally hot?"
However, if you're looking to
pinpoint a particular film that
took a heavy toll on Lautner's career
prospects, his 2011 starring vehicle,
"Abduction," ended up with a Rotten Tomatoesscore in the dreaded single digits: a measly 5%.
The film's box office results
weren't very encouraging either,
as the film grossed just over $28 million
domestically on a $35 million budget,
relying on its international box
office totals to turn a profit.
This might not have reflected too well
on Lautner as a bankable leading man,
seeing as "Abduction" was the first starring role
he did after the initial success of "Twilight."
This was his opportunity to show Hollywood he had
what it took to be an action hero and a dramatic
lead. "Abduction" not connecting with audiences
or critics seemed to signal that Lautner would
be unable to carry the franchise's success on
to other projects, and his acting CV since then
makes it fairly clear that productions have
been somewhat wary of casting him in leading
roles ever since. Lautner's last movie role
to date came in the 2016 film "Run The Tide."
"Are you serious?"
Though "Abduction" certainly didn't do any
favors for Taylor Lautner's action chops,
it doesn't necessarily mean that
his days as an actor are over.
Just look at his "The Twilight Saga" co-starRobert Pattinson, who spent many post-"Twilight"
years gravitating toward relatively obscure
and creepy dramas and arthouse films, and has
only recently started returning to comparativelymainstream fare, like Christopher Nolan's "Tenet,"
and Matt Reeves' upcoming "The Batman."
While Pattinson went artsy, Lautner has been quietly reinventing himself as a bit ofa comedian. He played Dr. Cassidy Cascade in
the second season of "Scream Queens," a serieswith plenty of funny moments, and he replaced
none other than Andy Samberg as the centralcharacter of the TV show "Cuckoo" after Season 1.
"’Cuz I can do this!"
"You can do what?"
"This! Right here! Maybe I'm
already doing it! I don't know."
In 2015, the "Twilight" star
had a prominent role in Adam
Sandler's comedy western, "The Ridiculous 6."
"Gol' dang!"
According to IMDb, Lautner is currently filming"Home Team," which is produced by Sandler's Happy
Madison Productions. Like "The Ridiculous 6," themovie is scheduled to debut directly on Netflix.
Apart from the occasional comedic role,
Lautner has recently kept himself busy with
real estate deals, as he bought a luxurious
mansion in Agoura Hills, California in 2020.
So even though he might not be the first person
Hollywood calls for action movies these days,
Taylor Lautner seems to be living his
best life, and keeps himself occupied
with fun projects that have very little
to do with his days as a hunky werewolf.
And if you're curious about revisiting those days,
the five "Twilight" films are currently
all available to view on Netflix.
"Thank you."
"No problem."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.